WILL GET THIS MEETING STARTED.
THEY'RE NOT FOR THURSDAY.
SEPTEMBER TWELFTH A LOVE AND A
ONE AND A TWO IN ONE BILL
AUTHORS AND MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
HE'S A- GOOD CALL ROLE. AND
THEN WILL BE PRESENTING THE
BILL THANK YOU. EDUARDO GARCIA
GARCIA PRESENT GALLAGHER
BIGELOW HELLO PRESENT CHOI HERE
CHOI PRESENT CHIU FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN PRESENT CRISTINA
GARCIA GLORIA KALRA LEVINE
LEVINE PRESENT MATHIS. MATHIS
PRESENT BLANCA RUBIO. RUBIO
PRESENT SALAS WOOD. WOULD
PRESENT OUR IS PRESENT GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AB
TWO FIFTY SIX IS A CLEAN UP
BILL FOR THE WINTER RISE
HABITAT INCENTIVE PROGRAM THE
WINNER RISE PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED BY MY BILL LAST
YEAR AB TWO TWENTY THREE FORTY
EIGHT IT PROVIDES INCENTIVE
FUNDING FOR FARMERS TO FLOOD
RICE FIELDS IN THE WINTER IN
ORDER TO CREATE WETLAND HABITAT
FOR MIGRATORY BIRDS. DURING THE
ROLL OUT OF THE PROGRAM AND
NUMBER OF GROUPS IDENTIFIED A
FEW TECHNICAL ISSUES IN STATUTE
THE LIMITED THE AMOUNT OF LAND
THAT CAN QUALIFY THIS BILL
FIXES THOSE I DIDN'T IDENTIFY
TECHNICAL ISSUES AND WILL
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF ACRES
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE A
LITTLE EMOTION IS SECOND DOES
HAVE A. CONCURRENT WITH THE
SENTIMENTS. THAT PLEASE.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE CHECK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RICE COMMISSION IN STRONG
SUPPORT SUPPORT AND URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. MONITOR GOOD
AFTERNOON. DUCKS UNLIMITED
WORLD LEADER IN WHAT LET'S
CONSERVATION WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT HIS BILL THANK YOU
MA'AM. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MERION WARMER DAMAGE FOR ALL
COUNTIES HOME OF RICE LANDS AND
WE ALSO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE AND FOR OTHER OF
THEM ON BEHALF AUTUMN ON
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS THE
CAUSE FOR EXAM HALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
CASEY NINE WE DO HAVE MOTIONS
SECOND THE CLOSING ACCOUNT SIZE
OF THIS ROOM OKAY TURNING
QUESTIONS ROBERT WHAT'S WILL
ROCK. THE MOTION IS TO CONCUR
IN SENATE AMENDMENTS EDUARDO
GARCIA GARCIA I GALLAGHER
BIGELOW. I WOULD THINK IT WOULD
BE A STRETCH THAT VERY HOW.
THANK GOD THE ROAD KILL BILL
THROUGH YESTERDAY OKAY. BIGELOW
I CHOI. HI CHOI I CHIU FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
GLORIA GLORIA I KALRA KALRA I
LEVINE. WITH EVERYONE SUSHI
SUSHI RIGHT. LEVINE I MATHIS.
YEAH YEAH THE FUNERAL. MATHIS I
BLANCA RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
WOULD WOULD HI. SIX EIGHT TEN
ON CALL OKAY WE'LL GET LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN WE HAVE A COUPLE
MEMBERS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
COMING IN AT ON SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND IT TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JUST WANTED
TOOK KNOWLEDGE CHAIRED FERGUS
IN OUR SCIENCE FELLOW TODAY'S
HIS LAST DATE. WITH US IN THE
COMMITTEE ONE THING CAM. THIS
SERVICE. THANK YOU
. THIS TIME
WE WILL LOOK AT THIS TIME
WALDRON OUR MEETING